the guys who you destroy just so
definitely on your podcast
on your youtube channel the ones who you
slice up
you're slicing them up and i'm actually
the real deal
investing companies when they're just
starting out i never take any money from
founders
i i wrote a book on angel investing
because i made a ton of money doing that
and it's 10 bucks or you can get it for
free i do teach of course angel
university it's only for accredited
investors and we donate all the money to
charity
if there's any profits from it jason 100
000 we did 100 000 in profits from that
angel university class and the reason i
teach those classes is because i want to
see more people
back founders so i am like the
in your world you have like the lex
luthors
and the super villains absolutely yeah i
am the
man of steel i am the dark knight yes
i am the actual real deal who actually
has succeeded and teaches a course
but the course is a hundred dollars or
three hundred dollars and basically it's
it's essentially free when you think
about it donate it to charity it's
donated to charity because we just want
to make sure that those incredib
investors
actually show up for the course right so
we charge them 100 bucks or
when we do it in person i think we
charged 500 and that included a 300
dinner afterwards and like literally we
broke even on it right so
anybody who's charging you five thousand
dollars for a course or ten thousand
dollars for this
and they're nobodies who've never
accomplished anything you have to really
just
type in their name tai lopez jt fox
brad whatever that guy's name was you
know them better than me
kevin david we can go down the list and
then just write review
or scam yep at the end of their work
name and then or better business bureau
and just look at what people are saying
oh yeah if you take the moment to do
that you'll find all these
people i think in almost all those cases
who say these people are scam artists
who are
trying to grift their grifters they're
great
on unfortunately the lowest economic
uh ladder of society yes and their
their goal is to take your money if you
if you're if you don't know what it
takes to be successful and you're trying
to improve yourself
they'll come to you with polished up
with all the trappings of success
unfortunately
we do live in like a a visual world now
where it's where
perception is reality you don't need a
background all you need
is a paid article in uh you know yahoo
news
from pr wire or whatever that's the scam
right
fake stories using people don't know
this but there are pr
wires basically a way to put a press
release out but you put the press
release out
and these grifters all seem to have
i think we should deconstruct the grift
i think i was thinking about how we
could be the most helpful together
because this is kind of like a super
team right now it's like
you're like this superman i'm like this
batman we could make the justice league
here
i kind of feel like this is a a moment
where we could both
put our skills together to deconstruct
the audience how you're getting grifted
you know you're getting grifted i think
one thing is when you see the
instagram and somebody like tai lopez or
jt fox what they do is i think the
technique
is this manipulation technique this
influence technique
is to put themselves in proximity to
other powerful people so they get the
halo effect and then to share
the trappings of wealth so somebody like
jt
fox has all these pictures of themselves
i noticed jt fox had a picture himself
with julia roberts
with mark wahlberg mark wahlberg
and then other people who i think you
can pay them 50 grand or 25 grand
they'll show up for anything
okay you're so right but can i tell you
how right you are
okay tell me how i tell you how this
grift works in actual
practice with a specific example there's
a man named clint arthur that i
i exposed like about eight months ago to
a year ago
clint arthur was a guy who basically ran
these groups
and he ran a fake harvard speech event
where he would go rent out a room in
harvard sell out a bunch of tickets
everyone in the audience had bought a
ticket to speak but they're sitting in
the audience as if people are showing up
to watch
and one by one they all go around the
podium speak at the podium it's all
recorded and then all of them put it on
their marketing material saying
i spoke at harvard talk about proximity
to the credibility oh my lord it's such
a perfect grit now
yes you you basically are co-opting
harvard yeah
so they all go to harvard and they spoke
at harvard
they were asked to speak at harvard you
could say harvard speaker
yep they spoke kicked out of harvard
they moved to west point they got kicked
out of there now they were speaking at
during covet they were speaking at the
cnn center
they went to the cnn center not
obviously he's not approved but they
rented out like the hotel room or
whatever
the cnn banner in the background the
guy's making
probably he cleared a million on sales
of this event
okay so this is the technique people
put themselves next to something
that we all respect in the world and
they hope to get that credibility by
association this is the technique
so let's put this technique as
credibility by association
but when you unpack it you realize they
have no affiliation
now compare and contrast this
i as an angel investor
was so lucky to have invested in so many
great companies
that stanford wrote a case study
on my ability as an angel investor and
networker
they actually wrote a case study so you
can go to the stanford business school
there is a case study written about my
career this
is how you are manifested by one of
these
you know business schools you either
went to that school you were a teacher
at that school or they wrote a case
study on youtube right that's really the
only way to be affiliated
oh yeah to be totally honest but these
folks have hacked it
do you ever wish you invested early in
some of the best performing ipos of 2019
and 2020 well our crowd investors did
invest early in many of those awesome
ipos with our crowd accredited investors
can invest directly and
easily in startups early before the ipo
or get bought
our crowd investors have benefited from
companies ipointing like beyond meat
and lemonade how about those returns
right and
some of the companies have been acquired
by buyers like intel nike microsoft and
oracle
the investment professionals at our
crowd have already invested
hundreds of millions of dollars in over
200 companies
with dozens of exits to show for it
today you can join our crowd's
investment in
nexa 3d a 3d manufacturing innovator
that's shaping the future of a projected
150 billion dollar market
nexa 3ds best in class solution gives
customers a productivity advantage
of 20x their competitors at up to 85
percent
lower costs you can get in early on nexa
3d and other unique opportunities at
rcrowd.com
twist i recently wet my beak and i
placed a bat
on siabra a company that uses ai to
uncover disinformation
and expose fake news on social media
what a great idea
you can wet your beak by going to
ourcrowd.com twist
signing up is free go ahead and do that
right now okay let's get back to this
amazing episode